- Today we're gonna talk about
Unemployment, Reemployment,
and Income Security,
or income insecurity as the case might be.
So, let's start with some something to get
our attention focused on that question.
- [Narrator] We're hauling
20,000 pounds of freight
down the Florida Turnpike
in a self-driving, robotic truck.
It's been retrofitted
with a self-driving kit
made by Starsky Robotics.
Kartik Tiwari and Stefan Seltz-Axmacher
founded the company in 2016.
- We think that sometime
towards the end of the year,
we could be doing this run
without a person behind the wheel.
- This year?
- Yeah.
- Self-driving trucks this year?
- Yep.
- [Narrator] And if it's not
his company, it might be OTTO,
whose truck made headlines last October
by driving itself across Colorado
to deliver a shipment of beer.
OTTO is owned by Uber,
which has also been
testing self-driving taxis
in Pennsylvania and Arizona.
But here's the thing.
Once our trucks and
taxis drive themselves,
what will happen to the people
who used to do those jobs?
In the US, that's 180,000 taxi drivers,
600,000 Uber drivers,
and three and a half
million truck drivers.
- We really need to start to think
very seriously about this.
- [Narrator] Martin Ford is the author
of "Rise of the Robots".
- [Martin] This is it.
- [Narrator] He says
driverless cars and trucks
are just the beginning
of a wave of automation
that will threaten millions of jobs
in every industry at once.
Like America's nearly five
million store workers.
- The cashiers are totally gone.
You're gonna end up with
the equivalent of a Walmart
with a handful of employees.
You scale that out,
and that's just
extraordinarily disruptive.
- [Narrator] You name an occupation
and there's somebody considering
a robot to take it over.
- Look how delicate.
- Perfect every time.
- [Narrator] At Zume
Pizza in Silicon Valley,
four specialized robots
help make the pizza.
Eventually, the company plans to replace
the remaining humans on the line too.
The common wisdom is that
robots primarily threaten
repetitive, blue-collar jobs.
"Not so," says Martin Ford.
- We're seeing dramatic advances
in the area of computers analyzing tumors,
recognizing medical scans, mammograms,
and being able to find disease.
We're seeing algorithms moving to areas
like journalism, for example.
- Wait, wait wait.
Certainly not journalism.
- Oh yeah, absolutely journalism.
By one account, every 30 seconds
there's a new story published on the web
or maybe in a newspaper
that's machine-generated.
- [Narrator] Algorithms
are even threatening
the masters of the universe.
Earlier this year, BlackRock,
the world's largest money manager,
announced that it's laying off
dozens of human stock pickers
and replacing them with robots.
By 2025, across the financial industry,
artificial intelligence
is expected to replace
230,000 human workers.
- Bring on the disruption
that is automation.
- [Narrator] Elisha Wiesel is
the chief information officer
at Goldman Sachs.
The company now hires nearly
as many computer engineers
as financial workers.
A quarter of these people aren't traders.
They're coders, writing
software to automate
the routine grunt work of
employees all across the company.
According to one recent study,
47% of American jobs could
be lost to automation
in the next 20 years.
- I'm sure 20 years from now,
almost no one will be driving a vehicle.
Young people are forward
looking and they say,
"Well, I guess I'm not
gonna have a driving career,
"so I'm not gonna go there."
- Well, except that these
young people might think,
"Well, maybe I'll go into retail,"
but that's also going away.
"Well, maybe I'm be a chef,"
"Well, maybe I'll be a paralegal,"
but that's also going away.
- So, let's do the
following thought exercise.
It's the year 1900,
and 40% of all employment
is in agriculture, right?
And so some twerpy economist from MIT
teleports back in time
to Farmer Pogue here
and says, "A hundred years from now,
"only 2% of people will
be working in agriculture.
"What do you think the other
38% of people are gonna do?"
- Well, I wouldn't know.
- Would you say, "Oh,
search engine optimization,
"health and wellness,
software and mobile devices,"?
Most of what we do barely
existed 100 years ago.
- [Narrator] In other words,
just because we can't
predict what we'll be doing
doesn't mean we'll be doing nothing.
- So, there you see the great debate
that is now being fostered
among economists and others
about the likely effects of automation.
On the one hand, there
are people who are saying
this is a fundamentally new
development, that these,
that essentially all
employment is going away
and there's gonna be
nothing for people to do.
On the other hand, you
see people say, "Well,"
as was said at the end in
the last part of that clip,
"In 1900, if people had had to speculate
"where everybody who was
gonna be put out of work
"in the agricultural
economy was gonna wind up,
"they wouldn't have had any
idea as to where they would go."
And so just as all kinds
of industries have emerged
over the course of the last century
that nobody could have dreamed
of at the beginning of it,
so the same thing will
happen in the next century,
and there will be all
kinds of new employment.
Life has more imagination than us.
People will innovate in new ways,
with techniques we can't even consider.
And that is certainly
gonna be an open question,
not a debate we would
settle in this course,
let alone whether anybody
else can settle it.
What is clear, though,
as I've emphasized in previous lectures
is that the idea of long-term
employment security has gone away.
And so our agenda today,
whether people are gonna
ever get new employment
or they're gonna work through a series
of up to 13 of 15 or 20 jobs
over the course of a lifetime,
the idea of a continuous stream of income
from one job that people get
upon finishing their formal K through 12
or perhaps K through college
education has gone away.
And so our agenda to day
is how to think about
the best responses to endemic
and permanent wage insecurity.
But I wanna do it with one
eye on last Tuesday's lecture.
We wanna think not only
about the economics
and the ethics of what we want to
consider as desirable policies
but also the political feasibility.
Where is it likely that
we can build coalitions
to actually implement
the sorts of policies
that might be desirable
and then find the resources for them,
the proximate goals to make
sure they move steadily forward,
the entrenchment to stop
them from being undone,
and the leadership to put together
and hold together the
coalitions to do that,
along with a moral narrative
that will be compelling to people
and can head off potential
blocking coalitions.
So, we wanna keep all of that in mind.
And I'm gonna talk about
four different topics
in connection with this.
The first is an idea that
has actually been around
since the 1970s.
Then this is the idea of UBI.
That used to stand for
unconditional basic income.
Now refers to the idea of
universal basic income.
But this is the idea
that people should be given
some kind of financial grant
unrelated to work,
unrelated to employment.
Second, we'll focus on minimum wages
and the political pressure
to put up minimum wages
in response to employment
wage stagnation and the
relative decline of wages
that we have talked about at some length.
Then we will look at
something called the EITC,
the Earned Income Tax Credit,
which is a kind of wage
subsidy that has also
emerged in the 1970s and
gets a lot less press,
but we, in my forthcoming
book with Michael Grant,
think is much more
interesting and promising.
And then finally we will
talk about the history
and prospects for transitional assistance.
There have been programs
since the Kennedy
administration in this country
to provide people with
transitional assistance
in moving from one job to another
that have not fared very well,
and we'll talk about why
and what the prospects for them might be.
So, let's start by going
first to the idea of an unconditional
or universal basic income.
(gentle music)
- Well, there is now,
in Europe and beyond,
more interest in the idea of
an unconditional basic income
than there has ever been
in the history of mankind.
Why?
Some people say it's because we predict
more automation, robotization.
There is some truth in that,
but this is combined
with a greater
uncertainty, greater doubts
about the feasibility,
the desirability of what
has always been offered
as the central answer to
the problem of unemployment
by both the right and
the left, namely growth.
And so if we think that growth is either,
continued growth is either
not possible or not desirable
and that anyway it hasn't lost
the problem of unemployment
despite all the growth we've had,
then it's high time to
think about something else,
think seriously about an
unconditional basic income.
A floor instead of a safety net.
Something that would be a
central element in any project
for a free society and a sane economy.
(gentle music)
- So, that is Philippe Van Parijs.
He is a Belgian political philosopher
who has been championing
this idea for some time.
He runs something called the
Basic Income European Network,
since renamed the Basic
Income Earth Network.
Was originally formed in 1986.
The book in which he developed this idea
was called "Real Freedom for All",
it's the subtitle,
"What (if anything) can
justify capitalism?",
which he published over two decades ago.
And he's a Rawlsian political philosopher.
You might call him a
sort of left Rawlsian,
and he took off from the core
insight in John Rawls's work,
in John Rawls's work
"A Theory of Justice".
And this is a, in the first instance
is a philosophical argument
for the idea that people,
every human being in a society
should be entitled to an
unconditional basic income.
And so what Rawls did,
and what was considered
to be revolutionary
and is at the analytical core
of his "Theory of Justice",
was he said, "Well, think
about the differences
"in capabilities between us."
Some people say, differences
in IQ for example.
Some people say it's all about genetics.
Some people say it's
all about environment.
And there, usually, there are these big,
ideologically charged fights.
Is it genetics, is it not?
Are there IQ differences
between different ethnic groups,
provoked Charles Murray and others,
got into these hugely
charged, ideological fights
over this question in recent decades.
Rawls says, "If the differences
between us are due to nature
"well, then it's luck
in the genetic lottery.
"If the differences between
us are due to nurture,
"then it's luck in where
you happened to be born."
Either way, it's morally arbitrary.
After all, you didn't choose
to have the genes that you've got,
and you didn't choose to
grow up in the country,
never mind the family that
you found yourself in.
You were either born into
or perhaps adopted into,
it's nothing to do with you.
And so the debate about
nature versus nurture
as to what people are entitled to
is really beside the point.
And this is sometimes called
luck egalitarianism because
Rawls made an argument on that basis
for the proposition that all
the differences between us
are morally arbitrary
and we should think about
principles of justice
that take account of
that moral arbitrariness.
And he developed his own theory,
which need not concern us here,
the bottom line of which was that
inequalities can only be justified
if they benefit the least
advantaged people in the society.
And he thought that that would trickle up,
a kind of Keynesian story if you like,
and that would benefit everyone.
So, Van Parijs had a slightly different
take on this Rawlsian insight.
He said, "What it means is that
everybody should be entitled
"to an unconditional basic income
"at the highest sustainable level."
Be up to political economists
to figure out what that is,
but that's what we should
all be entitled to.
It should have nothing to do
with our capacities to work
at different levels of productivity.
Should be independent of work.
And so this was the egalitarian case
for as high as sustainable
an unconditional basic income.
This generated a huge
debate among philosophers.
Nobody paid a great
deal of attention to it
outside of the academy,
and, indeed, a fatal objection
was launched, eventually,
by a philosopher called Susan Hurley
in a critique of Rawls in which she said,
"Well, you know,"...
This is, I put the
quotation up on the board,
but the gist of it is the following.
She said, "Well, it may be true
"that the differences among
us are morally arbitrary,
"whether it's genetic luck
"or luck in the lottery of
where we happen to be born
"and so no one is,
"in some natural sense,
entitled to what they produce,
"but why should that
create any presumption
"in favor of an equal distribution?
"It could just as easily create
some different presumption
"in some people's minds."
And so the gist of Hurley's point was,
actually, it doesn't justify
any distributive presumption,
including, perhaps, that we're entitled
to the fruits of our individual labor.
I'll come back to that.
So, it no more justifies a
presumption in favor of equality
than a presumption in favor
of any other distribution.
A case will have to be made,
and so it doesn't follow sort of
in any pristine, analytical sense
that we should be entitled
to have a distribution
that works to the benefit
of the least advantaged,
in Rawls's case,
or in Van Parijs's case,
it doesn't follow in any
analytically tight sense
that everybody should be entitled
to the highest possible
sustainable income.
And so the normative case
for this strong egalitarian
presumption sort of goes away.
Now, you might say,
"Well, that's all true,"
but particularly in light
of what we've been
discussing in this course,
there might still be a powerful case
for a universal basic income.
Not, perhaps not the highest sustainable
universal basic income,
but, nonetheless, it's
something that would
give everybody a cushion.
It would enable people to deal
with the vicissitudes
of employment markets
and the vagaries of
secure jobs that we
have been attending to.
And, indeed, one of the
presidential candidates,
who has just made it into
the debates last night,
is a strong proponent of a UBI.
So, let's give him a little more air time
than he got last night.
(students laughing)
- And you're running for
president based on this issue
of UBI, universal basic income.
What is a universal basic income?
What is your plan?
- Universal basic income is a policy where
every member of a society,
let's say every American adult,
receives a certain amount of money to meet
his or her basic needs every month.
And my plan, the Freedom Dividend,
is that every American
adult would receive $1,000
per month, free and clear.
- [Interviewer] $1,000 per month,
every American over the age of...
- 18.
This, to a lot of people,
is gonna sound like
a completely nutso idea.
So, just to be clear, has the US ever,
has any government body in
the US, existing or past,
ever done anything like this?
- Well, a law essentially
identical to this
passed the House of Representatives
in 1971 under Richard Nixon.
Martin Luther King was for it,
Milton Friedman was for it,
and a thousand economists signed a letter
saying this would be great
for the economy and society.
And then a number of years later,
Alaska passed something identical to this
in the form of the Petroleum Dividend,
where everyone in Alaska today receives
between one and two
thousand dollars a year,
no questions asked,
from the petroleum fund.
And if you think about this for a moment,
Alaska's a deep red, conservative state,
and the Republican governor
made this case to the Alaskan people.
He said, "Who would you
rather get the oil money,
"the government, who's
just gonna screw it up,
"or you, the Alaskan people?"
And the Alaskans said, "Us."
And then now the Petroleum
Dividend is wildly popular.
It has increased children's,
it's improved children's
health and nutrition,
it has created thousands of jobs,
and no one can touch it.
And that's been in effect for 36 years.
So, if you think about it,
what is the oil of the 21st century?
The oil of the 21st century is data,
AI, autonomous vehicles,
and advanced technologies,
and that's how we're gonna pay
for our Freedom Dividend
for all Americans.
I want everyone here to reflect.
Why is Donald Trump our president today?
And the reason why Donald Trump
is our president today is this.
We automated away four
million manufacturing jobs
in Michigan, Ohio, Pennsylvania,
Wisconsin, Missouri, Iowa.
All of the swing states
that he needed to win.
And now we're about to do the same thing
to millions of retail
jobs, call center jobs,
truck driving jobs, fast food jobs,
which are unfortunately the four
most common jobs in the economy.
I have many friends in Silicon Valley
who are working on this,
who know full well that this
trend is about to accelerate.
So, if we don't wake up
and start implementing
meaningful solutions
to the fact that we are going
through the greatest economic
and technological transition
in the history of the world,
then we are doomed to much,
much worse than Donald Trump.
(students murmuring nervously)
- So, that is Andrew Yang's platform.
And he makes some very,
very convincing points.
And if you think about it,
if you have a universal basic income,
it can also have a desirable effect on
relations within firms.
And this goes back to our
old friend Albert Hirschman.
If you think about...
If you think about a world, so,
where there's a continuum
from what we might call
a Dickensian nightmare,
where there's no social
support of any kind
for people who lose their jobs,
and at at the other hand
a surfer's paradise.
I use the term surfer's paradise because
one of Van Parijs's famous lines
was that even surfer's should be paid.
So, surfer's paradise,
it's Van Parijs's utopia.
So, you should, you
could then think that the
power relations within the workplace
are greatly affected by where
you are on this continuum.
Because if you are living
near a Dickensian nightmare,
where the costs of losing
your job are extremely high,
and your employer says to you,
"I wouldn't mind a cup of coffee,"
you're gonna scurry off
and get that cup of coffee
and come scurrying back quickly,
whereas if you are closer
to the surfer's paradise
and you could walk away from your job,
you might say, "Well, go
get your own coffee," right?
And so there was a thought,
there was big literature
in the '80s and '90s
which basically said that
if you, rather than trying
to have the government
produce more democracy within firms
to protect workers from
exploitative practices,
it would be better to just
decrease the exit costs
and then they'll have to treat you better.
Just as, for example, at Yale,
in 1992, the Supreme Court ruled that
compulsory retirement was
illegal, age discrimination.
And so the interaction of tenure
and the abolition of compulsory retirement
created a huge problem for universities.
And until that time,
universities had treated
emeritus faculty with contempt.
They had pretty much ignored them.
Once you were out of here,
you were out of sight, out of mind.
In order to get them to leave,
the superannuated people like me,
they had to start coming up
with much better retirement packages
to reduce the exit costs from employment.
They had to start treating
emeritus faculty better.
They built a building where
they can have offices,
they gave them email accounts,
and so on and so forth.
So, if your exit costs are very high,
you're much more vulnerable within a firm
than if your exit costs are low.
And so some people even
argued, and I was one of them,
that you might be able
to get business support
for a much more robust social wage,
giving people benefits that
are not tied to their work,
if you, on the other hand,
also promise business less regulation.
So, you'd say, "Well, if,"...
There were debates
about this, for example,
in the European Union that in countries
that didn't supply a lot
of worker protection,
maybe the social chapter
should provide stronger,
stronger appeals processes
when workers are abused and so on.
And the idea was that
since what business wants
is flexibility at the plant level,
you could try and get business support
for a coalition to increase social wages,
the quid for the quo being
that they would get less
regulation in the workplace.
It would be easier for
them to lay-off people
because it would be less
catastrophic for the people
and so on.
And so I and others pushed
these kinds of arguments.
The difficulty with them was
political, for the most part.
That because of the declining
power of labor anyway,
the notion that business had any incentive
to get behind these
proposals was pie in the sky.
And so they were stillborn,
and it's very difficult
to make the case today.
It might, nonetheless, be
true that we should think
that UBIs now is an
idea has time has come.
But why does it get so little support?
Now, you can get polls.
You can run polls where you can get
48% of the American public to
say they're in favor of it,
but they're standalone polls
that don't say anything
about the costs or how it would be funded.
And if you look at efforts
to actually produce it,
you find that people are very resistant
to this idea of writing checks to anyone
that are completely unrelated to work.
Why might that be?
- [Student] American work ethic.
- Work, there's a work ethic.
So, what is a work ethic?
(multiple students responding)
We must bootstrap ourselves up.
This idea that people
get something for nothing
or that they haven't done,
they haven't made the requisite
effort is extremely strong.
It's something that political theorists
sometimes call the workmanship ideal,
this idea that when you...
Working for something creates,
it creates an entitlement over it,
and because you know that,
it gives you the incentive to work hard.
And, indeed, if you go back
to the John Rawls's argument
that I mentioned at the
outset, he realized,
not surprisingly, he was
a very intelligent guy,
he realized that his moral
arbitrariness argument
was sort of at war with
the work ethic, right?
Because if you say nature,
nurture doesn't matter,
however you got your
skills and capacities,
it's all morally arbitrary.
You don't deserve, none
of you Yale students
deserve to be here, right?
There's no reason.
You just got lucky.
And you wanna say, "No, I
worked hard to get to Yale."
And so Rawls had a kind of cop out,
that he said, "Well,
yeah, the distribution
"of our capacities and
skills is morally arbitrary,
"but the, what we choose
to do with them is not."
So, if one person decides
to work hard every day
and has got lots of Protestant work ethic,
and the other one sits on the
couch watching ESPN all day,
then the one who worked choose,
even if they have the same capacities,
the one that chooses to work harder
is deserving of their
differential benefit.
But, of course, that and
two dollars and 75 cents
might get you a seat on
the New York City subway.
Because the capacity
to use your capacities
is also morally arbitrary,
arbitrarily distributed.
If one person has
parents who pump the work
ethic into them a mile a minute
and gets, teaches them, sits
and does homework with them
every night for 15 years and so on,
that's very different from a parent
who's maybe in an alcoholic
daze, ignoring their children.
And so the one child grows up
with the capacity to use their capacities
much better than the next person.
And, indeed, maybe the
capacity to stick at things
even has a genetic component.
Some people may be genetically
more able to focus,
all the research on
attention deficit disorder
and all of that.
So, Rawls's answer
is just a way of avoiding the
problem that he's identified.
And so here's the funny thing about Rawls,
and when I teach this in
political philosophy classes
we spend a lot more time on it,
but what you find
is almost nobody can see anything wrong
with Rawls's moral arbitrariness argument
except for his cop out,
which any smart student can
shred in a matter of minutes.
But nobody really wants
to go all the way with it
because it threatens the very idea
of individual responsibility, right?
Because how can you hold
anyone responsible for anything
if even our capacity to behave responsibly
is distributed in morally arbitrary ways.
And so even though it is true
that our capacities to do things
are distributed in morally arbitrary ways,
people don't like to live
with that implication.
Even if it's true that some
people got a lot of help
from whoever it is,
Sunday School teachers,
that other people didn't get
and more diligent parents and so on,
people do not want to live
with the implications of that.
And if you want a political
illustration of that,
think back to the firestorm
in the 2012 election
when President Obama
took the Rawlsian position
without the Rawlsian cop out.
- If you were successful,
somebody along the line
gave you some help.
There was a great teacher
somewhere in your life.
(crowd cheering)
Somebody helped to create
this unbelievable American
system that we have
that allowed you to thrive.
Somebody invested in roads and bridges.
If you got a business,
that, you didn't build that.
Somebody else made that happen.
- So, all hell broke
loose, as you might recall.
Here's just one of a million ads
you could've found in response.
- To say that Steve
Jobs didn't build Apple,
that Henry Ford didn't build Ford Motor,
to say something like that
is not just foolishness,
it's insulting to every entrepreneur,
every innovator in
America, and it's wrong.
- My father's hands
didn't build this company?
My hands didn't build this company?
My son's hands aren't
building this company?
Did somebody else take out
the loan on my father's house
to finance the equipment?
Does somebody else make payroll every week
and figure out where it's coming from?
President Obama, you're
killing us out here.
Through hard work and
a little bit of luck,
we built this business.
Why are you demonizing us for it?
(energetic music)
We are the solution, not the problem.
It's time we had somebody
who believes in us.
Someone who believes that achievement
should be rewarded, not punished.
We need somebody who believes in America.
- So, it didn't turn out
to be Mitt Romney, this,
but it is a portent of
things to come because
this ad was used to reinforce
the perception of sort of
"Let them eat cake" elites,
that he was sitting there in
the comfort of the Oval Office,
saying, "You didn't build that,"
and denying the efficacy
of the work effic,
of the work ethic.
And so you might say
it's a difficult case to make.
Nonetheless, you might have thought,
"I missed something here,"
because, as Andrew Yang says,
not only is he pushing this idea now
but he noted that people like
Charles Murray are supporting it
and, indeed, Milton Friedman has supported
a universal basic income since the 1970s.
But they have a slightly
different thing in mind.
So, here's Murray's
take on it.
- The basics are this.
At the age of 21,
every American starts to
receive a monthly deposit
electronically to a known
bank account of 13,000
divided by 12.
13,000 is the total basic income,
of which 3,000 must be
devoted to healthcare.
So, you have 10,000 of disposable.
I think if we simply add that on
to the current benefit
system, it's not affordable,
but what if it replaces everything else?
There's no more Medicare, no
more health, Social Security,
there's no more welfare, there's
no more corporate welfare,
there's no more agricultural subsidies.
I can go through the
whole list of transfers.
There's none of that stuff
and there's also none of the bureaucracies
that administer it.
You have $10,000.
And you say, "Well, you
can't live on $10,000."
Well, if you really wanna
live all by yourself, no.
You'll probably, you'll live a pretty
crubby existence on $10,000.
You get a minimum wage job,
just a minimum wage job,
and you work 2,000 hours a
year at, let's say, 7.50,
that's $15,000 plus 10, that's $25,000.
Yeah, that's well above,
way above the poverty line.
Well, suppose for some
reason you can't work
or let's suppose you don't wanna work.
You can still have a decent
existence if you're cooperative.
If you're cooperative
enough to convince a friend,
a girlfriend or boyfriend, a relative,
or something else to pool your resources,
if you just do it with
two people, you got 20
with no working whatsoever.
You got 30 if you got three people.
You add a little bit of income
and you're in the middle class.
That $10,000 given to everyone has a huge
effect on their ability
to live a decent existence
by doing reasonable things.
Right now, we claw back
benefits at a very low rate,
so that if you're on
food stamps and Medicare
and you take a job,
you very soon face a very
punitive loss of benefits.
I say, look, you keep your entire 10,000.
We don't claw back a cent of it
until you have 30,000 of earned income.
- So, there you have it.
The conservative case for
universal basic income
is something that would replace
the entire welfare state.
And if you look at the way
this has been costed out,
the Center on Budget and Policy Priorities
in Washington, DC, which is a think tank,
estimates that giving everybody a 12,000,
he says 13, taking three
out for medical care,
but at the 12,000 minimum wage
that somebody like Andrew Yang is pushing
would cost three trillion
dollars to fund per year.
And even if you got rid of
Social Security and Medicare,
that would not be enough to fund it.
And so if you start to think about
what would the political
coalition for this actually be,
it dissolves before your eyes
because the AARP would quickly
become a leader in the opposition to this.
You could think about universe,
hospitals, hospital interest
groups and administrators.
All kinds of people,
public interest groups
protecting welfare benefits,
would rapidly start to oppose it.
And it's also worth saying
that if you look at where
there have been efforts
to institute universal
unconditional basic incomes elsewhere,
they haven't fared much better.
So, setting aside
something like the Alaska
sort of windfall benefit
or the Norwegian,
the Norwegian Sovereign Wealth Fund
that's been funded by their oil,
which is a different idea.
It's a sort of...
It's a sudden...
A sudden benefit occurs and
there's a notion to take,
to spend it on the whole community.
But if you think in general,
in Switzerland they had
a referendum on a UBI
and it went down massively
and, by the way, was strongly
opposed by labor unions,
as you might suspect if
you start to think about it
because it would erode labor
unions' bargaining power.
In Finland they had a modest experiment,
a selected experiment with UBIs
to see what impact it would have
and abandoned it after a few years.
So, the notion that even
though it might appear
that you could get a great deal of support
for a universal basic income
and it seems like it might
not be such a bad idea
from a variety of perspectives,
I think that it's a tall order
to think your way through
a political coalition that
could effectively achieve
the kind of universal basic income
that most people would want
and be, certainly would
be willing to accept.
Between its sort of frontal
assault on the work ethic
that many people regard as necessary to
get people to be productive
and the fact that it would replace
some of the policies
that Americans are so
strongly attached to,
I think, Andrew Yang,
there's a good reason why
even though he made it
just into the debates,
he's not really getting much
attention for this view.
So, I wouldn't buy a lot
of stock in it right now.
Let's talk about minimum wages.
Of course, this doesn't
help with unemployment,
but it certainly would help
people who have been victims
of long-term wage stagnation.
- The fight for a $15 an hour minimum wage
just netted its biggest
victories yet this week.
Yesterday, lawmakers in
California voted for a bill
that will raise the state's
minimum wage to $15 by 2022.
On Monday, Governor Jerry Brown
is expected to sign it into law.
Last night, New York
governor Andrew Cuomo said
he reached a budget deal,
hiking the minimum to $15 in New York City
by the end of 2018.
Suburbs and other parts of the state
would reach that level in 2021.
The combined moves could affect
as many as 10 million workers.
- You know by today,
many of the CEOs of the companies
that we're fighting to get
the minimum wage increased on,
they have earned as much in the first
couple of weeks in January
as they will pay these
employees for the whole year.
That is not justice.
- That ain't right.
- That ain't fair, that isn't right.
And we don't begrudge anyone
their success and their income,
but we do begrudge
exploitation of the workers
to that extent.
- 90% of Americans have not
had a raise for 40 years.
- Pay your workers a living wage,
15 bucks an hour.
- It is a fight for fair wages.
- And so we could find clips of every one
of the Democratic candidates now running
calling for increases in
the minimum wage, at least,
at least $15 an hour
being phased in or not.
So, and this has been a constant
theme of American politics
that the Democratic party tends to fight
for increased minimum wages,
and there are efforts,
constant efforts to increase
minimum wages in urban,
within city and state
legislatures as well.
But there are a lot of difficulties
with minimum wages as
policy, when we think.
It's very easy politics, as
you can see, to make that case,
at least from the perspective of
the base of the Democratic party.
One question is, well, who actually pays
for increases in the minimum wage?
It might well be the case that
the cost of the increased wages
is simply passed on in
increased prices with the,
by the companies
that have to pay higher wages.
And, indeed, there was a
interesting effort to raise minimum wages
in Los Angeles a couple of years ago,
and we did some interviewing of employers
because the local Employers
Association was supporting it,
and they reasoned two things.
One was the money would be spent
in their stores in the city
so that it would come back,
but also that it would be
possible to increase prices.
So, it's not clear who
benefits in that sense.
But more indirectly, if
you're thinking about
what are the effects
gonna be on employment?
And here we have to think about
whether you'll get higher
minimum wages for some
at the expense of lower
employment in the economy overall.
And in some counties, this
takes on very extreme forms.
In contemporary South Africa,
as I think I have mentioned to you,
where they have very strong protection
of wages in the formal sector,
they have extremely high levels
of unemployment in the informal
and very different, much lower
wages in the informal sector.
And, furthermore, they have
hemorrhaged jobs to places like Lesotho
and textile jobs even to China.
And so there's a real cost, if you like,
of increasing minimum wages
from the standpoint of employment.
And particularly now,
when we're thinking about the temptations
to go to automation,
raising minimum wages might have even
more deleterious effects on employment.
I think I described to
you the Nike factory
I visited outside Ho Chi Min City,
and one of the notable
features of that Nike factory
was it was extremely labor intensive.
They were using technology
that was maybe 30 or 40 years old.
But the reason was that wages were low.
If you start to ramp up wages,
the incentive to send more jobs to robots
will become stronger.
So, the impulse to improve minimum wages
is completely understandable,
but it has these costs.
Moreover, in a federal
system like we have here,
if you increase minimum
wages in one state,
it creates an incentive for
employers just to go to other states.
Just as if you have strong
union contracts in one state,
such as the auto workers
unions in Michigan,
the employers can simply
move to Tennessee.
So, that's, there's a kind of internal
race to the bottom problem.
And if you have a federal
minimum wage, you can avoid that,
but only at the price of
contributing to outsourcing,
the flying geese problem and so on.
In an era when capital is very mobile
and can produce things
in anywhere in the world,
propping up minimum wages in one place
is water flows around a rock
and it's just gonna flow somewhere else.
So, it feels like a stop-gap solution.
It's also worth pointing
out, on the politics front,
how difficult increasing
the minimum wage is.
For example, we talked earlier
about the estate tax in the US.
When the estate tax was made permanent
in the 2013 legislation,
the threshold at which you pay
it was indexed for inflation,
so now it keeps going up.
Nobody has ever managed
to index the minimum wage,
and it has, that's why it
hasn't been put up for years.
There's very powerful resistance,
and I think that reflects
the relative weakness
of organized labor
in getting those kinds of
things entrenched, if you like.
So, even if we get, we
have a five year campaign
to get the minimum wage to $15 an hour,
it probably will have been
eroded by inflation by then
and a new campaign will have to be,
have to be instituted
to get it raised again.
The idea of
in 1988, Bill Bradley,
when running for the
Democratic nomination,
ran on the platform of
indexing the minimum wage
to the median income,
got nowhere politically.
A very difficult sell.
Now, you could say, "Well, okay,
"so if there's a race to the bottom,
"what we need to do is
raise the bottom," right?
And so can we think about
global minimum wage?
And there have been people
who have, and even movements,
that have committed themselves to this.
A man called Sullivan,
who was famous for the Sullivan Principles
applied to American,
he was a pastor
and the Sullivan Principles were applied
to American corporations doing business
in apartheid South Africa.
And the Sullivan Principles were,
they tried to force all the multinationals
operating in South Africa to say
they wouldn't do business in South Africa
except on these terms,
which defied some of the
worst features of apartheid.
They were quite successful.
He subsequently got behind
various other campaigns
to drive up wages in very poor countries.
And, of course, there's
some precedent for this.
If you look at the ILO,
the International Labor Organization,
they have created
international labor standards,
and, for example, in the 1984 Trade Act,
the federal government said they will not
trade with countries
that don't meet certain labor standards.
In the...
When the Bush admin, the
Bush Senior administration
negotiated the NAFTA agreement
and then Clinton came in,
it's true that he signed the legislation,
but not before so-called
labor side agreements
had been added to the, to NAFTA
which said that countries had to meet
certain minimum wage and labor standards
if they were going to trade,
sell their products in the US.
And so there are these efforts,
and they often involve sort
of publicity campaigns.
There was huge publicity attacks on Nike
for their labor practices
in sweatshops in Malaysia and elsewhere
that actually had a pretty good effect
on Nike jacking up their wages,
and Nike became an advocate
of pushing for increases
in global minimum wages.
And I, in an earlier book,
spent some time exploring
the prospects for this,
but they're very, very difficult
to achieve politically.
And even in poor countries,
they can have deleterious
employment effects
if the country's sufficiently poor.
So, it's not that it's a,
it's not that it's a terrible idea,
but if you start to think about building
and sustaining coalitions
that gonna be able to do this
in an era of highly mobile capital,
again, it's not an idea that is likely
to have much effect.
And certainly, if you look
at the amount by which
minimum wages have been increased
as a result of these
campaigns in countries
in East Asia and Southeast
Asia, they're minuscule
from a perspective of having
any effect on American wages.
It's very unlikely that
they'll be able to do that.
So, this is the difficulty
with minimum wages.
It's an idea that
is obviously appealing.
It's very, it's an easy soundbite.
You see all these Democratic
candidates running on it.
But in terms of having an actual impact,
it seems like it's not gonna do very much,
and it's certainly not gonna affect
the stability of employment.
So, let's talk about the
Earned Income Tax Credit.
This is a much less well
known about phenomenon
and although ideas of this kind
have been around for a long time.
Indeed, in Britain in the 19th century,
there was a poor law system
called the Speenhamland system,
which was essentially a
subsidy of very low wages
to keep people out of poverty.
So, it's a subsidy to business,
but it's paid to the worker, okay?
That's how the Earned
Income Tax Credit works.
And, interestingly, it was signed into law
by President Ford in 1975,
although it had begun its life
in the Nixon administration
and he had been overtaken
by events, but...
(students laughing)
The program survived, nonetheless,
and it started out very small.
So, the first Earned Income
Tax Credit worked like this.
You got a 10% credit
for the first $4,000
of your earned income,
and it then was phased out after $8,000.
So, the idea was that if your credit
exceeded the amount of tax you owed,
the government would write you a check
for the difference, right?
So, this is the idea of the
Earned Income Tax Credit.
That's, economists say it is refundable.
That's what a refundable credit means,
that if it falls below zero,
you don't stop getting it.
The government actually writes you a check
for the difference.
And so it took a lot of people
off the tax rolls entirely,
and then people would
start to get a check.
Now, you might say, "Well,
the numbers were so small."
Furthermore, originally it was for
single mothers with children only,
but here we should call back
the language approximate goals
that I talked about last time.
A very important book called
"The Hidden Welfare State"
by a man called Christopher
Howard was published in 1985,
in which he talked about the
world of tax expenditures.
This is a classic expenditure.
It's not seen as a transfer
payment in the budget.
It's called a tax expenditure.
It's an expenditure
through the tax system.
Even though the great majority of it
is the government actually
writing checks to people,
it's not tax refunds
because of the refundable character of it.
So, "The Hidden Welfare State"
is the world of tax expenditures,
and his book
gives chapter and verse
of the little-known truth
that the hidden welfare state
is actually as big as the welfare state,
as the visible welfare state.
Because what tends to
happen with tax expenditures
is that they start out small
and then they grow over time,
and so it's a kind of get,
don't worry that it's small to begin with.
Get your foot in the door
in the dark, as it were,
and then push to open
the door further later.
And an interesting feature is that the,
the EITC has had strong
bipartisan support from Republican
and Democratic administrations
and has been expanded numerous times.
By 2017, it was costing
the federal government
more than 70 billion in wage subsidies
to more than 25 million families,
and it doesn't now phase out
completely until $50,000,
which is above the median income.
So, it's 25 million families.
You're talking about 100
million people probably,
close to it,
are being supported, in some measure,
by the Earned Income Tax Credit.
They're either getting a tax deduction
or they're actually getting a check
from the federal government.
Now, this is...
This is not chump change, right?
Another feature of it
that is very appealing
is that it's very cheap to administer.
You don't need a new,
you don't need a new
bureaucracy to administer it.
It's administered,
basically, by the IRS, right?
You don't need a whole department
of the Earned Income Tax Credit.
So, that's an additional
feature of it.
And also, it has a very interesting
set of incentives attached to it,
which is, unlike a minimum wage
which creates the incentive
of race to the bottom,
this actually creates an
incentive of the race to the top.
Because if you have state
EITCs, as many states do,
what's gonna happen is if you, if
a particular state offers a better,
a more generous EITC than a
different state, all else equal,
the company will move to the state
that has the better EITC benefit
because it's a wage subsidy.
It's a wage subsidy but it's,
so it's making things
cheaper for employers
and so it can be a magnet
for firms rather than
a disincentive for firms to
move into your state.
So, this is a hugely
appealing feature of it
from the standpoint of
avoiding the race to the bottom
and, on the contrary, creating
an opposite incentive.
Another desirable feature of it
is that while it is a subsidy to the firm,
it's paid directly to the worker.
And if you think about that rather than,
say if you look at the infrastructure bill
that the Congress adopted last year
with tax breaks for firms
that invest in infrastructure,
one of the stock critiques
is it's very difficult
to make sure they actually
make those investments
in the infrastructure.
They do the planning in
R&D and the planning,
and there's money paid to consultants,
and maybe they do it or maybe they don't.
Or if you think about
place-based incentives
to firms to move to different areas,
there's lots of criticism of
them by economists that they,
that they lead to a lot of clientelism
and corruption and so on.
When your payment is going
straight to the worker,
there's no, there's a much
smaller possibility of that.
Now, economists will still object
that this is distorting labor markets,
and some people think
it's morally obnoxious
because it's giving firms
incentives to pay lower wages,
and it does give firms
incentives to pay lower wages.
Nonetheless, you can
see the potential here
for a coalition.
And, indeed, business has tended to like
the Earned Income Tax Credit.
I think that it's one reason why
Republicans have tended to get behind it.
And certainly in the last decade,
the increases in the EITC
are by far the biggest
increase in downward
redistribution that we have seen
at the hands of the federal government.
This is, I think, genuinely is an idea
that has time has come,
and you should think about
the likely expansion of the EICT,
EITC as a way of
generating employment and increasing wages
that is going to have
more rather than less
of a future.
Of course, it is, the
other reason Republicans
are willing to get onboard with it
is that it's linked to work.
There's no, this is unlike the,
unlike unconditional basic income.
You only get it if you actually work.
Nonetheless, employers can keep wages low,
knowing that they're gonna get the subsidy
for providing the employment.
So, I wanted to spend
our final few minutes
talking about unemployment
and adjustment assistance.
Again, I think an extremely
important set of policies
in view of the,
the insecurity of insistence.
Now, unemployment insurance
in America is a very,
has a very depressing history.
If you go back to the
Social Security Act of 1935,
there was a lot of talk at that time
of creating a national
unemployment insurance system
based on a tax you pay when employed,
but there was a strong body of opinion
that said the Supreme
Court would strike it down
as unconstitutional for technical reasons
that needn't concern us.
So, instead what we got
was unemployment legis...
The unemployment system was created
as part of the Social Security Act,
but essentially it's a kind of
unfunded mandate on the states,
and all the federal government
supplied was some guidelines
and some administrative support,
and in particularly extreme circumstances
such as the Depression or
after the financial crisis,
the government, the federal government
will make lump sum contributions
to sort of prop up unemployment
insurance in the states.
But basically, it's a state-based system.
And that immediately has
one very bad feature,
which is state legislators do not want
to have very generous
unemployment insurance
because they worry about the race to them.
They don't wanna be paying it
and so there's a lot of
resistance at the state level.
The benefits that they
create, state unemploy,
they're often very short-term,
they replace about 40% of prior earnings,
and they mostly don't keep
people out of poverty.
There's particularly low
coverage for low income workers,
so it's not a good country
in which to be unemployed.
And, indeed, the short-term
character of the support,
the hurdles to getting it,
and the prevalence of
longer-term unemployment
I was telling about in an earlier lecture
may mean that in 2016,
only about a quarter of
the unemployed workers
in America were receiving benefits,
down from over a third
in 2007, so, you see there the effects
of the long-term unemployment
and the difficulties of getting it.
And also another thing that's happening is
that more and more long-term unemployment,
employed workers are
just choosing to go onto
Social Security disability benefits.
Applications for disability
insurance have skyrocketed,
so they're leaving the
workforce permanently.
Again, it's a very costly solution
to the problem.
And because the wages that are taxed
to fund unemployment
benefits, there's a cap,
it's also a very
regressively financed system.
So, the unemployment insurance in America
is never been robust,
it's difficult to get,
and it's failing badly
I think is about the best
that you can say of it.
But there's a more
interesting set of programs
that I wanna end by
spending a little bit of,
a few minutes talking about,
and this, this is the idea that was known
as trade adjustment insurance,
trade adjustment assistance,
and it was a missed opportunity
politically for the,
because of the way in
which it came to be enacted
and then implemented.
So, it was adopted in the
Kennedy Administration in 1962.
This was an era of trade deregulation,
not unlike the era in the post-Cold War,
and the Kennedy administration
really wanted to
get trade agreements with other
countries to improve trade.
And the unions were a lot
stronger then than they are now,
and the way the administration
got the unions to support it
was to get behind this idea of
trade adjustment assistance.
And it was gonna be...
It was going to be robust
unemployment insurance
coupled with
funds to support relocation
and free retraining.
And so the AF-of-L-CIO supported it.
They supported the Free
Trade Act on the grounds
that this would be the quid
for the quo, if you like,
to use the language of the week.
That we would start to get
this adjustment assistance
paid to workers.
They would get better unemployment,
longer-term unemployment support,
and they would get support to relocate,
and they would get
free retraining to
re-enter the workforce in,
in another occupation.
It was a huge administrative catastrophe.
President Kennedy was assassinated,
and when the Johnson
administration came in,
they had different priorities,
and they were doing civil rights,
they were doing voting rights,
they were preoccupied
with the Vietnam War,
so this was not a high
priority of the administration,
and they didn't set up an
effective implementing strategy
for this program.
And so throughout the 1960s,
actually, not a single claim
for trade adjustment assistance
was actually funded.
And business had been very
skeptical of this program
and had not really supported it,
but as the 1960s wore on
and the desire for free
trade agreements in
many sectors got stronger,
business decided that
they liked this idea.
But by then, the AF-of-L-CIO had concluded
they had been so badly
burned that George Meany,
who was it's head and who had
actually championed the idea,
he rechristened it burial insurance,
and the unions have since
opposed all free trade measures.
And so it's really a lost opportunity
because it was the one
time in American history
that American unions had actually been
in favor of free trade.
A real lost opportunity.
And this is an idea that
has really taken hold
in some other countries.
The gold standard here is Denmark,
which supplies 60% of your
lost wages for three years
plus huge amounts of retraining
for workers to re-enter the workforce.
Very tailored to individuals.
They spend a lot of resources on it.
This to is an area where
we argue in "The Wolf at the Door"
is an idea whose time has come,
but it has to be rethought
in the following,
I'll just finish with this,
has to be rethought in the following way.
One of the problems with it was that
the unions had a lot of
trouble supporting it,
not only because they had
thought they had been burned
but they said, "Why
should we only help people
"who've lost their jobs to trade?"
Indeed, one of the reasons
it was so hard to get it
was you had to prove you'd
lost your job due to trade
rather than for some other reason.
They said, "That's unfair
"because what about industries
where people lose jobs
"that are not due to trade?"
And, indeed, in the Reagan administration
when they decided to essentially
underfund the program
so much as to effectively kill it,
Reagan made exactly the same argument.
He said, "It's arbitrary
just to help people
"who've lost jobs to trade."
Well, in our era,
where jobs are probably
increasingly going to technology,
as we have heard about,
it should be re-conceived
as universal adjustment assistance,
and I think it would
be much easier to build
and sustain the coalition to protect it.
So, what business should fear
if they don't get behind
these kind of proposals
is that Andrew Yang will
turn out to have been right.
(students laughing)
And just, we'll let...
I'll leave you with this
epitaph on the 2016 election,
and I won't tell you who said it
until after I've read it to you.
Trump's election wasn't about Trump.
It was a throbbing middle finger
in the face of America's ruling class.
It was a gesture of
contempt, a howl of rage,
the end result of decades of
selfish and unwise decisions
made by selfish and unwise leaders.
Happy countries don't elect
Donald Trump president.
Desperate ones do.
In retrospect, the lesson seems obvious.
Ignore voters for long enough
and you'll get Donald Trump.
Yet the people at whom
the message was aims
never received it.
Instead of pausing, listening,
thinking, and changing,
America's ruling class withdrew
into a defensive crouch,
beginning on election night.
Well, that's enough of it.
We're out of time but it's Tucker Carlson.
You might be surprised to know.
All right, we will see
you after next week.
(bright music)